[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive coming up we'll see
what's making the headlines
with the consultant editor of the daily
mail andrew pearce and the associate
editor of the daily mirror kevin mcguire
and they'll be with us right through
until midnight for our extended news
review
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages now the telegraph says that
downing street has told head teachers
they have to stop
sending whole school bubbles home to
self-isolate
when just one pupil tests positive for
covid
the guardian has a story about the
safety of hosting the final stages of
euro 2020 at wembley
after scottish fans who traveled to
london for a match tested positive for
coronavirus
the us and japan have been conducting
war games and joint military exercises
so they can react if there's a conflict
with china over taiwan
that's according to the financial times
the mirror
leads with princess william and harry
reporting they're putting aside their
differences
as a statue of their mother princess
diana is unveiled
the sun looks ahead to saturday's
quarterfinals saying harry kane
will do an italian job on ukraine in
rome
three lions go to rome alone the
headline in the metro
and the daily star has a story about
celebrities getting botox
i'm joined tonight by andrew pearce and
kevin mcguire good evening to both good
to see you
so that story on the front of the
guardian fears
over mass events after uh large numbers
of traveling scotland fans tested
positive for coronavirus kevin
yeah no absolutely they're very big
figures at 2000 scots
may may have been infected watching
watching football including 400 who were
in wembley 1
300 in all who came to london because of
course
a lot of them came without tickets and
had a good time but that's a 400 figure
if it was in wembley scotland had 2
600 tickets to that game so that's 15
those figures are way ahead of what we
what was recorded in the test events
uh including the fa cup final pop
festivals
uh this will snoozer up in sheffield
lots of other
other events are very high it could be
because of the nature of watching
football is is very close blood to
hugging and certainly in london
lots of drinking but the good thing is
the
link has been broken between infections
and hospitalizations and deaths we saw
that in the figures
today the uk wide figures which showed
the number
of uh infections at 26 000.
that's the highest since the end of
january when it was 29
000. but back at the end of january was
29 000. there were 1245 deaths
reported in the 24-hour period now there
are only
14 because so many people are vaccinated
way over 80 percent
uh uh at least one job uh and including
that as well as 60
have had two and it gives a lot of
protection and those who who tend to go
into hospital
and tend to die alas are unvaccinated
or have underlying conditions yeah
but this is a big concern isn't it
andrew about these
traveling fans particularly when we've
got the semi-finals and the finals
coming up with increased capacity at
wembley
for them these were fans who were
infectious
at the time they traveled according to
public health scotland but they didn't
know it
so inadvertently we're spreading the
virus to those on the trains they
traveled with wherever they ended up
yeah i know but look what's the
alternative do we just go into
stay at home and not go out again do we
do we just stay in
splendid isolation we just got to learn
to live with this wretched virus
and kevin makes the point and i agree
with him even though these numbers are
higher
much higher than than we saw at some of
the trial events such as the
the the big art events and the concerts
where just a handful of people
um contracted kovid um
a lot of the people will probably be
younger uh i saw a lot of those fans
in central london uh before the scotland
match
uh they were in leicester square where i
do a radio show for lbc
there were thousands of them they were
under the most of them were in their 20s
and 30s
there was no social distancing there
were no masks there was a lot of boozing
they were all greeting each other very
warmly and embracing so
uh i'm not surprised but because of the
the because
um the the vaccination rollouts
proceeding ahead
i don't think we should pull up the
stumps now and think okay
let's stop people moving around the
country we've got to get on with our
lives again now and we're getting ever
closer now
to july the 21st and we've got a health
secretary now
who's determined to get us out of these
wretched restrictions i think the
country's
at the end of its tether with them now
actually we've put up with this for long
enough now and then when you get idiots
like matt hancock
gayley breaking the rules which he made
and
elected the rest of us to adhere to i
think the chances of people
uh staying at home and sticking at home
are very limited
uh matt hancock is now facing uh
pressure in his own constituency
that phrase there we've got to learn to
live with kovid one we heard from the
new health secretary sajid javid this
week
uh kevin one of the ways we need to
learn to live with it is keeping kids in
school
uh the daily telegraph with that story
schools being told not to send home
entire bubbles
yeah it's quite interesting the
telegraphs say the downwind street the
prime minister's spokesman has said this
you can't to get heads to change policy
just on that
because the education secretary gavin
williamson who is so useless
even andrew thinks he's bad and said
they're still looking at it but he hopes
to change
uh the the rules but it may not be
before the summer holidays and if it's
gonna it'll be changed after
some holidays you need to tell schools
quickly because the figures in england
are
incredible 395 000 children
at home and that's about one
in 25 because one or two pupils will
test positive
in in a bubble which might be a
a class it might be a year group and
then everybody is sent home
which means they miss education and it
creates utter
chaos for parents who are working and
the proposal is after trials
is to replace doing that sending
everybody home on mass
with testing in schools daily testing in
schools i think that's the way forward
but the telegraph is saying right
down in the streets uh something i
didn't hear uh said this i didn't know
the prime minister say it uh today
at uh at prime minister's questions i
didn't hear
uh i'll see a press conference in dallas
because there wasn't one
uh the education secretary wasn't as
certain
it's what he hopes to do but he hasn't
said it's going to happen so schools
and heads who have been incredibly
flexible and have tried to twist and
turn with government policies and
andrew normally attacks teachers and
thinks they're inflexible that's not
being the case
they work brilliantly and they've been
very very versatile
but they need proper guidance from the
government it can't just rely
on a daily telegraph story based on
something
a prime minister's spokesman has said
that does not
well gavin williamson did say today is
going to announce this and he's hoping
to do this in the next
phase of it lockdown easing didn't he
andrew head teachers will
presumably be welcoming this keeping
children in school as much as possible
but the one message we've had throughout
this pandemic is they want clarity
they want to know exactly what they're
meant to be doing and they want plenty
of warning
they do can i just say kevin guys as
usual
utterly misrepresents me i do not always
attack teachers
i think teachers do a great job in that
on the whole what i do though is
attacking his mates in the teaching
unions which seem to spend more time
trying to keep teachers out of school
but in the classroom their job is to
educate not to keep causing trouble
as for the as for this story though i
think it is amazing the telegraph has
discovered
36 schools in england are closed
altogether
because of david and yet the problem the
probability is only a handful of kids
had uh symptoms of covid it it is
ridiculous and i just and
we're now talking about testing every
day for children
well that was being floated back in
january by that
intellectual titan called gavin
williamson the education secretary
and the idea elapsed and went away and
now it's coming back again
i think they've just got to get on and
sort it out because these kids
cannot afford to miss any more education
tuition at home
as a lot of moms know uh and dads no
is not easy uh the poorest schools are
often
unable to provide decent teaching online
so let's get them back to school even if
i i mean i think they should start next
week if they can but i suspect it'll be
in september
yeah and i know it's the lesser of two
evils but wow daily testing of uh
three children at home might make for an
interesting experience
let's stick on the front of the
telegraph and and
and the idea of a jab in each arm so
combining the flu vaccine roll out with
booster vaccines for coronavirus
according to the jcvi
kevin yeah starting from september back
by jonathan
van tan the deputy medical chief medical
officer in
in england who is a fantastic
communicator uh and
the idea is yes from september it'll be
the over 50s and vulnerable people and
it is again
how we how we learn to live with code
it's not going to disappear it'll
probably never be
eradicated or certainly not in the
foreseeable future so it's how do you
deal with it and
one of the ways is keeping people uh
immune and we get those fantastic rates
in the vaccines uh 92 percent
uh astrazeneca 96 with pfizer
and scientists are so clever and
adaptable and nimble you can see that
improving as they tweak it and
learn to cope with new variants coming
along but it does mean
right in the in the autumn get along uh
those of us
uh who will qualify and i consider it
needy get along get a flu job but also
get you
your booster uh it's it's gonna be
permanent now you just feel it just
going to be part of the nhs
is that combating this this wretched uh
virus because it ain't going to go away
and if we want to have our
lives back in the better parts of our
lives to to return
we're going to have to have to remain
jabbed andrew it's all very well on the
domestic front isn't it dishing out
third doses for people but when you've
got other countries that are struggling
to get access for first doses for their
populations how does this look
it's it's it's a terrible dilemma of
course and um we have got
a huge extra capacity because the
government um
unlike uh kevin's mates in the us
european union
bought masses and masses of vaccines
early on
but i think the first job of the
government is to get this country
healthy
uh and uh and i think we might if we do
need booster jabs in the autumn
then we must have them because otherwise
the alternative is we get dragged back
into a lockdown
and nobody wants that nobody wants that
i'm pretty sure sajid javid when he took
that job has held secretary made it
absolutely clear to the prime minister
only if we come out of lockdown on july
the 19th and we're not going back in
we will be able to help the rest of the
world at some point we are going to
start giving some
jabs i think it's in september uh that
was all announced at the g7 summit
not as many as we we would like to but i
think we've got to put britain first
okay um let's have a very quick look
kevin at the metro
and uh a ceasefire in the sausage walls
that's right this is the the government
uh agreement the treaty protocol that
the government boris johnson and
negotiated signs said was fantastic he's
unready deal and so on but of course we
know it's not
because it's created problems in
northern ireland with the border down
the irish sea but there is now a
ceasefire on chilled meats until
september
so this isn't a problem uh resolved it's
a problem
uh postponed as negotiations will go on
but the fact is
the government signed up to it and they
always blame the european union but they
were
selling this as an excellent deal only a
few months ago
because they were either either blind or
ignorant or
just willfully lying about its impact
okay quick thought from you andrew
before we head to the break
well i hope by september the 30th when
this three-month truce
uh expires that that dreadful angela
merkel woman
in germany will have finally stood down
she's been there far too long
they never know when to go and we may
get some reasonable behavior breaking
out in the european union would help
people more she take
the horrible president macron with her
too you sit on the fence there andrew
we'll see you in just a moment let's
take a brief
pause coming up more from the papers
including a reunion for the royal
brothers and princess william and harry
preparing to unveil
a statue in honour of their mother
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
there are hundreds of these turbines
[Music]
that's what's left of the north tunnel
this is a show of strength shrapnel from
that explosion this is nearly a week off
the tag it's a complete scene of
devastation
to the heart of the stories that shape
our world
we're not sure about the road we're
going to try and find a way out of wuhan
we help you understand the world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
done
[Applause]
hello or like we say in my language is
relay
i am tonitiv the founder and the ceo of
renewables in africa this picture
changed my whole career
and my whole life my mission is simple
is to bring back power
to africa and our idea is to turn the
dark continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous one by
2014.
[Applause]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now andrew pierce
and kevin mcguire we're going to turn to
the mirror
front page now uh andrew and
prince harry back in the uk seen him
tonight for the first time
and he and william are apparently to put
their differences to one side for their
mum tomorrow
yeah well normally all eyes would be on
what the design of the statue of
princess diana that they're going to
unveil tomorrow in kensington palace
uh is to mark her 60th but what would
have been her 60th birthday
uh in july but actually all eyes would
be on the body language between these
two brothers who once was so close
who can never forget the image of young
harry and william walking behind their
mother's coffin at that funeral
back in 1997 but the feud between the
two
is well known now harry has spent a lot
of his time in the united states
pouring scorn on the royal family
enraging prince william
but i think the fact that he's not
brought his wife with him
will help matters uh kate middleton is
staying away too
so i suppose it won't highlight quite so
much
that um meghan markle isn't going to be
there her excuses she's looking after
the baby i think it's a fairly good
excuse she's only just had a baby
but i think we i think we also know that
there'd be a pretty frosty
reaction for her after all the abuse
she's held at the royal family
and of course don't forget she's still
the subject of some serious bullying
allegations and an investigation into
all of that
at the palace i mean kevin can they
put those differences aside or is it
just a show
tomorrow i mean we we wondered whether
the duke of edinburgh's funeral might be
a catalyst for them
coming together and it appears not yeah
i think andrew was a bit uh
characteristically hardhearted towards
megan parkel there when she has as you
say
not at all not enough just had
a baby but you would hope they would be
able to bury their difference and their
mother would bring him
together i'm not really sure why we're
having a statue put up with it
uh i hope at least i hope it looks like
it's not gonna be like one of those
ronaldo
statues that isn't is uh nothing like it
but the uh the fountain that winter
they are putting her on and never worked
i think it's just dry now something
comes in parts but they're going to put
up this statue they're both there
and you would hope they can just start
on a human level
just seeing them as two individuals two
young men who as
boys suffered the unimaginable
tragedy of losing their mother very
publicly and
in such a horrific car crash and i
thought rather cruelly were made to
march behind the uh the funeral carriage
and you just hope they can begin to bury
their differences and it's going to take
time
because they've grown so far apart and
i'm a republican i'm not not a royal at
all
but you would just hope on that human
level that the two can
somehow just find that more unites them
and divides them and they can just begin
to get on because it must be awful when
a
family splits like that yeah we run out
of time for the the metro
three lions go to rome alone uh
no chance for england fans to get there
but we will talk about that in the next
hour
kevin and andrew thank you